[Musique]
mais bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette veste c'est quoi ça un pardon
personnes pour plein coeur forcément
très bien c'est le stylisme qui m'a dit
un quart arrière garde n'a pas tendance
à new york
musique latino de quelle année la mode
merci beaucoup le voyaient là module
géraldine maillet la voix l'a adoubé lui
[Musique]
en d'autres endroits on est prêt
- voilà donc la batterie nous donne
chauffeurs gardes pour la laponie
mais c'est tout chaud
d'un avocat par un vérin zizou avocat
puis je mélangerai du régime pour sa
survie
[Musique]
ouais je vais faire des révélations
pour
merci mon invitation
le
ration
/
ils comprendront couler
accor niveau là je parie mes copains ici
ici et ici je vais shania niveau là on
joue ta chute québec
oui
[Musique]